what's up everybody is Mac Miller you're
watching improv imagination right here
on GQ Richard Branson to me is one of my
favorite people in the world because
with all of his money he got a spaceship
so the first thing I would do I'd take
the spaceship in a spaceship we need one
of the new curved TVs we're gonna be
watching a turtle sunshine of the
spotless mind when we feel emotional
animal house when it's time to turn up
then all the women will be dressed in
blue why blue because who wants to go to
a party looking good I sure don't I
would like to go to a party looking like
a [ __ ] so we're gonna do is we're
gonna take my dad's suit when he got
married he was about 700 pounds he is
three legs also has wings so I'm just
gonna be my father this is an all free
game we're gonna go back down to the
planet land right on Branson la Island
oh there's a DJ who has a stick Alex and
the party crew all of them have matching
outfits we have the pinata and inside
the pinata our little piñatas and when
they fall out there's a bunch of free
ride passes to the unicorn flipper and
unicorn flipper it's always been in
trouble for the kids because you sit on
the Unicorn and what happens is it's
kind of like a mechanical bull and it
goes back and forth back and forth back
and forth and pushes you off and you
usually get impaled by the horn so they
had to cancel that but we got to do it
it was fun then of course we have to
check out the volcano I'm standing there
I put my hand out and all of a sudden
adored opens and Richard Branson walks
he says no use your left hand use my
left hand and I've realized that when
you put your left hand in it it's not
actually lava but it's all of the
answers to the questions that you've
been asking about the government and
where you really see yourself going next
ten years get transferred into my body I
then find out the meaning of life so
then I'm gone and they're still left
with a bunch of unanswered questions
sucks for them subscribe to GQ for more
awesome videos like this and in the
comments below why don't you tell us
about your epic party event
sir
you